I'm going to draw a tree that's already mostly filled out.
This tree uses numbers like 5 and 3 and 1, 6 and 8 and 13,
but it follows the same principle we talked about before.
For any particular node like 5, all of the children I can reach on the left are less than 5,
and all of the children I can reach on the right--6, 8, and 13--are greater than 5.
Now I want to add 7 to this tree,
and you're going to help me out by telling me where it might go.
I've drawn 7 boxes with sort of dotted edges,
and these represent possible new nodes that I could add.
What I'd like you to do is check all of the boxes where I could legitimately add a node for 7
to the sorts of trees that we've been talking about.
Check all the boxes that apply.